[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we did and I'm sweating like a pig in
Miami home of sandy beaches terrific
weather and plastic surgery true this
was how I looked before I got here what
an improvement Thank You Miami but here
we are for the big game so I guess that
means it's time for so we've gone over
the accomplishments of Donald Trump many
times economy piece dead terrorist's
trade deals stock market but now we can
add life expectancy for the first time
in four years
America's average life span has
increased yeah things are so great under
Trump people don't want to die anyway
you've already heard this good news a
million times for me and to be honest he
was right we're gonna win we're gonna
win so much we're gonna win with our
military we're gonna win on trade we're
gonna win at the border we're gonna win
so much you are gonna get so sick and
tired of winning it's true I am kind of
tired of winning but you know who wasn't
the Oakland Raiders of the 1970s what a
team
ferocious brutal scary you had Matuszak
Tatum Alzado the great Monty Johnson
they were scary monsters and super
freaks but there were also winners
mainly because of their boss Al Davis
controversial intimidating but he lived
by three words
Jess twin baby and boy did II from 67 to
85 his team won 13 division
championships one AFL championship three
Super Bowls but people put up with his
rebellious streak I see one sound
familiar
Trump is the out Davis of presidents and
his administration they're the Raiders
of old and their mantra just win baby
like the Raiders Trump is not only
defined by his base but the people who
hate him and the hate for Trump is
strong especially
in the media wing you basically say
several days after this bombshell from
John Bolton yeah we don't want to hear
it we don't want to know we don't want
you to hear it or or know it that sounds
like they're participating in a cover-up
it's actually maybe worse what Lamar
Alexander is doing because he's saying
essentially yeah yeah he'd meet his wife
so people around the world are watching
us going this is what you want for the
rest of the world I mean what a sad sad
moment the American people are going to
have a complete view of just how ugly
this drug deal was by the time November
rolls around and just how guilty the
president the United States was thanks
Beavis or is it Butthead I'm never sure
and they hate is so strong it actually
includes his supporters Donald Trump
couldn't find Ukraine in a map if you
had the letter U and a picture of an
actual physical crane that's next to it
he knows that this is you know an
administration defined by ignorance of
the world and so that's partly him
playing to their base and playing to
their audience you know the the the
credulous Boomer Rube demo that backs
Donald Trump that wants to think that
the dog Trump's a smart one in there oh
yo yo elitist rube now if that was a
slot machine that would come up three
bags
and the reason is it's not Trump they're
bashing it's you you dumb rube for
supporting him but you know who else
hates you and Trump let's see well you
got Hollywood you got most academics and
yeah the head of Iran mandiboy a
yarmulke no I hate your country your
president and everything about your
culture you are the vomit that comes out
of pigs after they eat their own filth
you are the scabs on the knees of
lizards who suckle at the breasts of
obese and diseased rats
Balaam mikonam except for that greg
gutfeld
or as we call him in iran sultan of late
night he is much funnier than Jimmy
sunup Kimmel
on second thought if the United States
throws in a pair of tickets to see the
Greg Gutfeld show then maybe we have a
deal yes but I'm starting to like that
guy not sure about the translation
anyhow you always know someone is doing
a great job by their adversaries level
of discontent impeachment for example
reflects that frustration they can't be
Trump's results so let's just throw the
game so here's my final football analogy
impeachment is like the Super Bowl for
losers you got two teams one wants to
impeach and one wants to acquit are they
the same
no one team started training for this
game the day Trump got elected they
trained to impeach those are the losers
the other side they were just trying to
do their own job and so far it's pretty
damn good which may be why Don Lemon was
laughing so hard to keep himself from
crying
[Applause]